[Música]
o top 90 mais um vídeo e um sinais com
fazer no bristol de star wars que para o
desbalanço papel mas vocês quiserem
podem aumentar o tamanho do carregadores
interessaram e para aquilo então 20
balas para fazer estudado folhas tamanho
a4 com aquelas que nós usamos um aumento
para imprimir em casa o lask com uma
caixa de cereais de pequeno-almoço uma
caneta e muita cola e vocês quiserem e
puderem utilizar óculos de proteção
agora os contatos trial passo a passo
então vai lá
[Música]
o
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
ah
também compositor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o
aquelas outras
[Aplausos]
[Música]
to
o
o ponto alto é um desafio e espero que
vocês tenham gostado desse projeto aqui
estava explicar que gostariam de ver no
próximo 23 opções a primeira é um tem
feito cartão que andar pois tem cabeça
lucrativa e prepara também uma bala
depois tem mas na época como sistema de
molas 90 elásticos mas agora tem um
sistema do moleque para muito bem e
depois tenho uma arma neve que eu posso
fazer um bom jogo aqui para o canal nos
comentários que vocês gostariam de ver
que no próximo vídeo